on a toujours vécu seul ma mère et moi
avoir une famille c'est tout ce que je
désire
je crois pas j'ai un cousin j'ai jamais
vu un mec aussi blanc il veut me
rencontrer ma mère a toujours eu envie
de m'emmener en angleterre pour en
apprendre plus sur notre famille il va
bientôt y avoir un mariage tu de revenir
t'es sérieux
c'est magnifique mais
je présume que c'est une invitée
important et vit une relation proche de
la famille walter de ville un sauté en
chanter j'ai hâte de mieux vous
connaître et vie
ils font quoi en bas vous devriez
retourner dans votre chambre
quel est le futur marié le marié et son
épouse feront leur entrée en grande
pompe le 2 mars
c'est la curieuse impression que tout le
monde me regarde peut-on leur en vouloir
le courant a l'air de passer entre eux
walter étoilé
je serais curieuse de savoir ce qu'ils
patinent
sur
les semoirs cardy
la voile où sont le mari son épouse
comme vous le savez tous il manque une
personne cette table
mais ce lien qui fut autrefois rompu
sera rétablie ce soir
notre nouvelle mariée
je veux rentrer chez moi mais tu es chez
toi
préparez la devoir
je ne m'en parle ainsi
et tant pis s'il
tiendrait à l'eau c'est monsieur harker
il y a là une jeune femme qui semble
être en difficulté